dude I wish I had some sage or some Palo
Alto just smell this wafting candle
right okay that's good are you ready for
that yeah okay ladies and gentlemen
we're back again for the movie reviews
on your favorite podcasts
all right
no mic for Steve today alright I just
want to keep a positive house I was
already freaking out at the Comedy Store
the other night oh yeah I met all those
oh my gosh a list
comedians really meet Joe Rogan and acts
like a maniac I couldn't look at him in
his eyes people just who it you would
hello look at his chest I'm a big fan of
Joe Rogan I listen to it all the time I
sleep with it
I lay down it's like a part of my a part
of my ASMR sometimes I'll listen to like
a lot of his stuff and actually meeting
like the person the real Jill wrote like
the person my mind was you had no idea
what I was going through my mind was
like spinning you know like in like my
eyes cross I would be like Oh what are
you gonna do when you meet somebody I
know I know that's what your concern is
all right so do you think Joe Rogan's
gonna go to a little dungeon it was all
like heavy hitters so in that hallway
it was Whitney Cummings yeah Marc Maron
Jill Rogan you and Kevin keep Christie
yeah I don't get nervous around you or
Kevin yeah you just get weird
I know did you did you see that Marc
Maron had Leonardo DiCaprio and Brad
Pitt on his podcast yeah no he did it
yeah yeah I think he had him on the part
cuz he had a picture he was like look
who's on the back and whatever it was
that's probably a dope one I mean he's
cute I mean he doesn't have to do
anything why is he even doing Kony all
he has to do is podcasting it was you
because when you're a comedy writer you
know all right now it's your passion
again can you imagine if Leonardo
DiCaprio was like ice-t me I'm a fan of
yours can I come over to your pocket you
here I'm like you know I bring it to you
I'm like hey man I was at the Comedy
Store
Leonardo DiCaprio was there and he was
like do you don't Steven Lee from Stevie
we be show alternate reality [ __ ] okay
I'm gonna roll with it and when
personally I would sweat profusely I'd
be sweating I'm a big fan of his dude
would you big fan you meet him outside
or work in the past great freaking even
remember Basketball Diaries we start
with Leonardo DiCaprio let's go with our
top 10 Leonardo DiCaprio movies what you
got uh that's not to do five because
that's like my mind that's I like
basketball uh Hollywood yeah the most
recent well he's grown on me actually
since I got to I got the screener when I
first thought I was like ah this is so
boring a lot of stuff I didn't like yeah
but it really does grow on it does so
I'll give I'll give it its due um and
what's the is there a one with him Romeo
and Juliet oh yeah Romeo and Juliet but
it was like MTV version of them and then
aviator you gotta throw maybe a view
like a v8 or what's up catch me if you
can he was good in that one too
can you meaning you know so at least I
survived it six right there oh wow you
did do circuit six yeah but you're not
even gonna what was the one the first
course AZ wait hold up he did another
one when he was younger I think it's
called this boy's life the one where
he's Robert De Niro or know what's the
way that wrapped in arrow oh the one
where he was like troubled kids right
yeah he mentally you yeah yeah he was
What's Eating Gilbert Grape
sorry that's yeah and that was with uh
what's-his-face uh wasn't that with with
that axe barrel guy Johnny Depp Johnny
Depp yeah this is like trivia I'm trying
to remember yeah
well then you got that Beach you got no
blood blood blood diamond oh you had the
one was still a weird one on the island
um that's that's Tom Hanks castaway no
oh sorry it was like just like like he
was like a cop or something on an island
and it was like uh there was like a
psychiatrist thing there where's my
[ __ ] phone let's just oh no he was
good in that other Tarantino movie uh
django Django Unchained
he was he's been in too many I mean he's
been in too many good ones you know oh
well here's okay so here we go man like
beautiful Wall Street on the spot Dallas
what do you want an Oscar for the
revenant where the Bears are look at it
like this and catch me if you can you
said the Great Gatsby wasn't a fan of
that what about that how do my computer
turn on yeah I thought that was out of
commission it's not but that was just so
freakin haunt oh no no you know what it
is it restarted because it was already
plugged because of what you being weird
I'm sorry um let me see the quick and
the the quick and the dead life yeah so
this boy's life that's the name of
right I was right on that one where's
this boy's life this boy's life okay
that's a different movie though okay
wasn't the one Robert De Niro that's a
holder I was thinking about different
one but we don't know you might be right
about that
listen Errol now Ellen Barkin yet De
Niro's okay
oh good for you yeah okay oh yeah so I'm
trying I think when you will you look
back at you know much too much at his
body of work yeah and not only that it's
his longevity throughout years I mean he
since he was a kid he's been doing
steady work yeah there's only a select
few people that have been working since
teenagers since the whole way through
right yeah and I was like a huge star
yeah and what I like about him too I
think he has more good movies than bad
movies oh yeah he's gotten better as
well yeah cuz some people is we're like
they're like Eddie Murphy Eddie Murphy I
would say it's like 5050 problem yeah
Eddie he's such a I know but there was a
large there was a large chunk of movies
going through the 90s and he was making
weird movies yeah I know I just put
anything he is in everyone's gonna watch
you know everyone yeah including both of
us yeah
yeah I'm looking forward to uh I don't
know so it's 2020 uh what movies are you
looking forward to watching this these
upcoming you know I don't know I haven't
really seen because I didn't really
enjoy too many movies I really didn't it
what as I'm getting the screeners from
the sags yeah we should both watch it
yeah I heard that's that's supposedly
really good everybody keeps talking
about that but like you know like I saw
I saw yeah parasite parasite so another
thing that caught me off guard was you
know there's the rich people that lived
on top of the hill yeah but then there's
also the twist of there's like a hidden
bunker room like some North Korean weird
underground yeah that was bizarre but
anyway yeah that was a great movie so
that's one of the movies that I thought
I was really good I thought Joker was
good I thought but I didn't see that
many of the movies you know I'm look at
these screeners and I'm like I didn't
watch a lot of these movies I saw the
irishman I thought it was boring as hell
did you see that I haven't
so boy you got it yeah you know Morsi
wasn't go Pesce yeah but I've seen but
here's my part here's my point like you
know they did this crew have done a lot
of movies together
I mean Goodfellas is one of my so I've
seen better movies yeah with them in it
is it can you put it in the same box as
casino and Goodfellas not even close in
my opinion some people are like this is
a masterpiece isn't it like four hours
that's like it's really long alright
what's it about it I mean I'm gonna see
it eventually but you can spot Jimmy
Hoffa this has been a nightmare park
it's about Jimmy Hoffa yeah the labor
guy from back in the day why he died and
and you know this speculation about the
Kennedy assassination and look and all
of these things a day how he was
involved so that one was okay yeah um I
don't know I'm not sure what I'm looking
forward to seeing in the future do you
have any movies yeah
it's called Gretel and Hansel oh not
Hansel and Gretel no it's it is Han says
it is the tale of Hansel and Gretel but
I call Gretel one called I think Gretel
enhance if you look that up they won you
know cuz they're like we gotta have the
women first it looks kind of like more
of like a horror like a horror or more
version a mythical horror
kind of yeah Gretel in Hansel yeah yeah
you know later it is 2020 film yeah 2020
and the thing if you look up a
supernatural horror retelling of the
classic German fork fork fork lore
mm-hmm a grim fairy tale okay yeah if
you look at the the trailer it's it
looks kind of scary it looks like a
horror movie I might put the trailer
I've been doing some edits now oh so you
know yeah I might put the yeah so that
one that's probably the only one I'm
looking for
1917 as well but that's already out I
just I do want to see it cuz everybody's
talking about it yeah yeah sure
I heard uncut gems as good as oh I
haven't seen that want to see yeah
that's like his best work yeah Oh dark
waters was good with my flow yeah yeah
you kept talking about that but isn't
that like sort of like a you know Erin
Brockovich yeah it is basically but with
a guy yeah it's about du Pont like
poisoning the water
I hate those type of movies yeah I hate
those kind of feel good Mark Ruffalo fan
there you are yeah yeah yeah like I like
his work top six movies Mark Ruffalo or
you could count on me The Avengers dark
waters and then the ones you said yeah
all right well I did bring Steve off
spur for a particular reason but he's
got notes for it having notes did you or
did you watch mandalorian first you
watch them no I went to I went to the
real premiere screening of it right
like whether the pilot yeah these
episodes show Korea yeah so that I only
seen three oh did you like it yeah it's
really great I mean I've never been to a
red carpet event and yeah and so when I
went I I was actually with his son with
John farver old son I didn't know it at
the time I met him at I went to Bobby no
not through Bob through Dave David Cho
oh wow yeah so Dave invited me to a live
drawing there was a nude model there oh
wow so that was crazy there was a nude
so you cheated on your girlfriend no no
but we're there driving the nude model
and then he goes yeah this kid's gonna
meet us there and I think he told me
there I was because he this kid ended up
we went to cuz Dave's like do you want
to watch the mandalorian after the art
workshop and I go yeah cuz I thought it
was on Disney Plus we're gonna go to
someone's opposed to watch it but we
ended up going to the real premier
premiere or like the actor like Kathleen
Kennedy was
overall was there the whole cast was
there it was at the elcapitan
it was a whole thing so we went there
and I'm like where are we going on we
going to someone's place and they went
on the boulevard we wiped park near the
Jimmy Kimmel lot thing and then we start
going in the back alleyway and I'm like
wait a minute this is like we are like
doing so this is different so we get
around to the front of you know we're
like there's like tables and stuff and
I'm like that's when I'm like okay this
is like we're at the real thing this is
something real this is some real [ __ ]
yeah so and then so his name is Mac so
shout out to Mac's by the way it was
that's John's son Max like dipped and
got like the REO laminated passes of
mandalorian oh wow so we got us the
passes that's when I'm like okay we're
this is the real thing like this whole
time you like used you're still kind of
curious like where are we going right
now we go in and have you been to the El
Cap yeah it's an event dude like so we
get in there and so I'm like they're
like oh you gonna get popcorn and I'm
like all right I didn't have I don't
have cash I never have cash yes we saw
Ventures endgame there Steve yeah did
you go with us well it was me Craig
Pikachu I wasn't okay so anyway so they
gave us a tub of free popcorn in the
mandalorian like the plastic and they
give us free coke they gave us
everything was free so I'm like okay
this is really special because because
you already know how frugal I am so at
what point did you go oh man a movie
premiere that's when it really hit me
when it started no no no when in the
concession to the concession stand right
when and then the people were dressing
like tuxedos oh wow I'm like wait a man
this is and you were just like a bomb
I'm sure it was just like a Hollywood
guy like I don't know so you don't leave
my apartment personally so we get there
and we already have like they're like um
yeah we already had designated seats and
everything
and then I noticed that um there's a guy
that looked familiar familiar like like
I turn around I'm like that guy looks
familiar
it was Apollo Creed oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was that dude and his whole
family was he's in it yeah yeah so I'm
like oh did you shake his hand like no I
but my mind that's what my mind was
spinning and so okay so the lights went
out off and then back on and then like
the of the presenter went on stage it
was like hey thanks for coming out
everyone are you ready for a Mandalorian
blah blah blah blah and then guess who
walks out who Kathleen Kennedy she comes
out and I'm like I was just frozen yeah
I was like and then like present it and
then they had like um leather seat sir
like lockers and couches on the stage
okay so do a meet and greet after they
had a question so they had the whole
cast on stage in the beginning Wow
and so I'm like oh my god this is the
beginning cuz maybe we didn't like it
they don't got to deal with it and I
know it would be a weird Q&A let's say
people hated it and then you have to do
a Q&A after yet and there's that weird
energy in the crowd yeah yeah so they
did that and then I thought it was just
one but they showed all three at the
beginning before he was even out yeah so
they should I had like y'all's texting
Craig what you think of it I loved it I
didn't know like you know I didn't know
that universe that deep like I didn't
know what a Mandalorian like yeah by the
way I don't think anyone did okay so
yeah but Craig was explaining these like
dude you know Boba Fett oh yeah Boba
Fett he was like yeah that's he's a
Mandalorian oh my god I consider myself
at Star Wars nerds yeah yeah I didn't
know I didn't know that I was happy with
the third one with the one where they
show the Jawas remember they show the
Jawa
trash compactor that vehicle in the sand
I'm like boom Jawa yeah it was good I
like it's a great series you got to
watch the end of it it's really good so
how many episodes are there there's
eight a tempest okay yeah yeah yeah and
it's like it's really great it's a
really compelling story yeah so um so at
the very end I had to go the bathroom
when I came back up the the stairs Dave
and Max and we're there with our friend
Paco visiting for the Philippines he
they were standing near John farver oh
and they're like Steve get into the
group picture so I like I got you have
that picture yeah it's um I put a I did
it on my story but I can repost it you
should have your story yeah I got a
picture you gotta put on your main page
Steve I'm not utilizing my social media
in an effective way yeah yeah you're
right you're right I should have put on
my said so that was a special event yeah
and so Jon Favreau's here and I'm in the
pit you know I'm taking a picture with
the director you know and then after we
ate at Mel's Diner with his son and like
I was just oh you had a whole day he's
picking his brain about house I told max
I'm like hey how does your dad get these
ideas cuz you know ya wrote it and I'm
like and this is one thing he told me I
don't know if I should be taught uh you
know I don't think this is a positive
thing yes Father he was like um you know
my dad always has father beats me no no
nothing like that but my dad always have
a notebook write and feel with like
illustrations and just feel with like
just notebooks of stuff and he just goes
into a room and just right going yeah
you got to do it yeah yeah you do your
music right similar energy well I have I
know I have always have a notebook
around
and whenever you whatever your
inspiration is it just comes yeah well I
if I have an idea I write it down but
then if but then if I get more ideas I
just kind of add to it and then and then
I think of visuals as well that's good
yeah yeah well glad you like that so
that's into like why we're here today we
asked you about this before I know that
there's like a Yoda type you know I saw
the baby Yoda I don't want to know more
I don't know
we keep saying baby Yoda but like euros
name was Yoda I don't know what the city
I don't know what the species of a Yoda
yeah they're green low goblin creatures
nobody would be like calling like you
know like you see another human being
and yeah like a baby and I call that
like I was like oh that's a baby's Dee
yeah yeah you know well there's like
Lake of the mandalorian that's a that's
the group the subcategory you would call
that group a mandala Mandalorian well
they're not a race though their
organization like a Java you know what a
Java is you know or San people you know
what a San person yeah but it's a nice
walk you know what you are but a sane
person could be a Mandalorian if they
trained Yeah right
yeah they have to put the mask on or
take it off tough it out yeah which is
kind of weird yeah no one could ever see
your face yeah that's such an awkward
thing right I don't like that and I want
to get to that because I had a problem
with specifically
okay before you go to your notes Steve
okay we're going to talk about Star Wars
the rise rise of sky rise here's an
extensive rise of Skywalker review
between with Steve and I
can I explain just contacts to hold on
okay okay so here we go what do you
think I want to just kind of like a
notes guys give you context of the ninth
cuz I was a memorable night oh this is
gonna be another 35 minute cuz
Bob Bobby was involved I was in Walnut
with my girl it was raining that oh this
is great alright so your mother I was a
right nut and then I kept getting it on
my girlfriend I want to watch crisis
character could we go tonight she's not
into it
no she want to see it but she we were
gonna do it later that week or saw her
go let's see it's night come on it's
like Sunday or whatever it is like and
then my brother was texting me like hey
I want to see it so he met us at the
Puente Hills Mall Wow do you have you
heard of this mall no yes probably that
kind of like the most it was it's a bad
mall oh it's just you know it looks like
it's from the 1970s
well there goes our endorsement from the
not gonna be giving us any ads for the
blast the theater so the mall is crap
but the theater is H because they have
IMAX Danka so this IMAX it was raining
okay you saw it IMAX yeah we got the
IMAX and you Baba know in our Lani yeah
my girlfriend I lon Wow so we're there
and I've seldom we have I been to a
theater where it's leather seats mm-hmm
and it was like a electronic lazyboy
I'll do where you could went up yeah and
you're like oh dude I'm like chillin
yeah so we were there and and then
another thing can I also add on that I
was looking over boilers not not movie
spoilers but just reviews previously
like us specifically geeks and gamers on
youtube and everything was so negative
about the right everything was just
bashing it I'll forget how the JJ
every mrs. Crabb Kathleen Kennedy ruined
the whole yeah just a bad negative
negative everything was negative I saw a
couple positive from people I know like
lately like Dane Cook went to the
premiere and then I hit him up like how
was it he was like he loved it but so
not everybody hated him but go on
yeah and so I was like I was already at
a place mentally where I'm like oh this
is I'm not expecting anything I just
want to see it that's why I don't like
it when people ruin my experience you
know I don't like that it's like before
I have a chance to see you there's let
me decide exactly and not only that
you're there they're ruining my movie
experience I want to because I want to
just be entertained okay real quick
though before you go into that my story
about when I saw it as I was in
Washington DC you know okay you're on a
comedy you know I wasn't I was actually
just visiting my cousin for a night so I
went to DC and then I was like let's go
see a movie and you know she's never
even seen any Star Wars and she but she
came with me she doesn't know but when
we left a movie theater she was like
that was dope that's positive it's so
positive so anyways alright go on well
that's interesting to me because it's
like the the geeks and gamers stuff's
coming from like a super like insel fan
base they're like they have their
nitpicking every little but someone
that's never seen Star Wars before and
they just liked it as a standalone movie
kind of emotional I I teared up a couple
times
me too and I was like what is so funny
cuz I was in the theater like crying
about crying - yeah there what what
moment was it I don't know what it was
but it was all towards the end at the
end it was all towards the end I cried
at the end yeah I was literally I
thought that was a great shot of like
her like where Luke it's like it was
kinda the trajectory was going back one
it like back to the beginning like that
I like first of all there's that but
before we begin cuz I have notes on
specifics that's a big task for
Abraham's cuz Rian Johnson already
[ __ ] up last the last Jedi right I
thought those it's like dude that's a
large task to like cuz we talked about
this at Korean barbeque you're like dude
we're he was trying to make up like yeah
he was trying to fix this [ __ ] that they
put together but I don't think today
well I just I'm saying with what he had
to work with I give this movie a B+ I
give it a b-minus it wasn't be plus it's
a B minus B so then combined we've given
it a B a B ok so and it's just because
of some of the things that they had to
fix from the with with from this
ridiculous story that they were telling
so they tried to like fix it with some
things and I thought he did the best he
could so what you got what's your no
okay so I'm gonna start with the
positives
go ahead the things I did like about it
okay you say and then I'll respond okay
okay so I like Finn and pose chemistry
their dialogue throughout the movie it
reminded me of like chewy and Han in the
old ones I thought that was it was
entertaining for me and it made me feel
good okay how many respond to that I
thought that like I agree with you but
because in the first one you could tell
they were pushing it and they didn't
know each other and it was weird I feel
like JJ Abrams is obviously a better
director in terms of getting that out of
the right right his they were they did
they had a good like you felt like these
people have known each other for a
little while they had a camaraderie old
school you know that I totally agree
with that so I felt that a good
chemistry chemistry the dialogue was
somewhat funny too
what's her next good coin um I like and
and hear me out on this one I like the
look that aesthetic look just the way it
looked of Palpatine Sith underworld you
know where oh I like the look of it and
remind me of like if you know like David
Fincher directed that segment it was
dark I like the way there was that huge
block that building were they had a wah
and then there's that entrance point at
the bottom I looked I liked the way it
looked on the inside and look it looked
like a vampire can't calves
or something I like that so his secret
underworld okay the look of it there's
just the light so the look of it is
positive because I have some negatives
about it yeah you do yeah because my
negative about it is just where the [ __ ]
was this all this time yeah you know so
you're telling me that yeah he can build
- this is what I don't understand
they had a planet killing gun on two
hundred ships all right I want to get
that's I have that at my notes okay but
I'd say so what my help my negative on
it was just like it just it seemed too
unrealistic it just seems so ridiculous
that this was going on in the galaxy and
nobody knew come on cuz they didn't
build these ships overnight you know in
the first - right where the shipyards
like you know is there a company putting
stuff together they're working no this
was just how'd this happen
everything is new with Palpatine in his
introduction - you're just gonna bring
in a modern oh we're you're not gonna
give us any foreshadowing and Bob
brought that up he's like I don't know
where yeah it's because cuz once they
killed Stoke right them fixing the [ __ ]
I don't like the way they killed stone
either do I that's like this guy I like
how they killed him but I didn't like to
hit you know tell me this dude is the
Sith Lord master and he don't see the
lightsaber right here kylo Ren good is
gonna do like boom you missed you then
you missed the whole point of that right
there what the way he died yeah you
missed the whole point of it the what
what's his name Stoke was looking inside
his head kylo Ren was fooling him making
him thinking that he was gonna kill her
right and that's why the the everything
he said was happened all I see what
you're gonna do you you're gonna cut her
but you you're gonna fight your enemy
you know I'm saying yeah and what he did
but he was the enemy okay we're trying
to imply with that alright I just agree
with you like the way I mean cuz but
that's the reason why we're the who's
the arch-nemesis now you know if it's
not him there's got to be another
powerful Sith Lord had to be so but the
thing is it Bobby Bob didn't sit well
with Bob since it what with me yeah but
go on okay
I liked and you might disagree in Bob
disagreed
I like the reintroduction of lando
calrissian I'd like just I just like
this now Joe it was nostalgic it made me
feel good seeing him but but the
coachella event or whatever we you go
where the [ __ ] have you been
and Bob brought that point yeah that's
how I feel by yourself like as a
storyteller and a writer how are you
gonna even have that's gonna be thirty
minutes of the movie to tell you where
Lando they've killed everybody else so
you gotta bring him right everybody else
is dying han solo's dead you know we
already got you Blackie here Princess
Leia's like whatever so yeah there's
that that many characters left yeah
you're right we probably hit him up like
hell Billy Dee Williams you want to do
okay so uh so you like that good I like
that
it was nostalgic it made me feel good
alright especially him and chewy in the
made me feel good all right it felt good
that felt good about the movie okay I
like the new Droid the D - o0o the
little drew yeah that little droid they
would try so hard these droids though
you know like rights but the Moche I
never like to bb-8 all right I like the
droids and I actually think I'm gonna
put this out there I think if they're
gonna do more content with Star Wars
it'll be great for me I would love to
see like a mini-series on like destroyed
destroyed Smith's and I'm gonna get to
my last positive thing about the most
the thing that got me okay I love the
most is uh what's his name Abu Frick who
the [ __ ] was that it was the little cute
little guy that was working on c-3po
that little oh yeah so Babu Frick Babu
Frick and more Babu Frick I love see him
I love Betsy race yeah on Disney Plus
you want the bad
no not particularly on him but just
because he was a droid Smith right and
that's a thing that you see droids miss
kind of like glimpses of droid Smith's
in Empire Strikes Back you know in Cloud
City when they captured c-3po you'll see
little droid Smith's in that little in
that little dungeon lion-o
area so I just thought that he was just
made me laugh just whenever he talked I
was laughing okay those are weird
positives I would just say like you like
none of that has to do it with story um
with the characters with the story let's
get your negative boo thick is your no
his name's Babu Frick Babu Frick is your
pot you not only was it your body I
loved him it was your major positive so
you really did you in the future there
might be a little Babu for tattoo on my
ankle
who knows who are sick okay so now we're
gonna get to the meat and potatoes you
get to the meat potatoes problems of
rise of Skywalker Leia Leah's lightsaber
so Laius got a lightsaber dude
this is okay and hold on on top of all
that that's a way a ray with Luke's and
Leia's she's gonna do like that
Excalibur freakin move like this and
that itself is gonna kill Palpatine well
no that's not what killed problems but
she deflected powers it was all the
Jedi's inside her I didn't like that
either the collective versus the Jedi
think I didn't like that okay but before
let's start with this so we already
talked about how they had to fix the
[ __ ] that they already have so they they
were handed a pile of [ __ ]
and they said fix it so they had to come
up with like all this like ridiculous
backstory that but you can't have
backstory on a story that we already
know you don't mean it would be like it
would be like exactly you know what
we put that it would be like changing
like like how spider-man became
spider-man yeah Uncle Ben survived he
was jumping from the building system and
that's my just add that and then not
only that remember that segment of young
Luke and Leia doing the Jedi training
but really that's them that's how they
that that's the backstory part they were
like trying to like patency like you
don't know what was happening between
Return of the Jedi and this so she was
training absolutely what I did know all
I knew about the force and Leia was win
uh Luke Skywalker at the end of Empire
Strikes Back was telepathically like in
Cloud City on that pole that was
foreshadowing that she had she could
possibly be a Jedi so that's what that
was okay no I'm I'm talking about
something completely different back to
your spider-man analogy it had her
wielding a lightsaber no listen yeah
that was after obviously the training
came post Return of the Jedi
obviously well no it happened with it
when there yo I know post or Return of
the Jedi okay
they weren't brother and sister yet
until Return of the Jedi right right but
it showed the training when they're like
2018 Return of the Jedi they they
weren't close until that time and even
know each other before that she didn't
even know he was his brother she was he
was her brother until return till return
you got you got you got you so and then
and then when Return of the Jedi and I
got like you know remember when the
thing blew up and then Han Solo's like
is she I hope Luke's not on there
I don't think so what I'm saying is they
foreshadowed a couple of times that she
could possibly be a Jedi
so I'm actually personally I'm okay with
I'm okay with it okay but sit well with
me that's okay I Specter your opinion no
but yeah it just doesn't sit well with
me
but they like I said they force
oh did twice now this is what my problem
is in rise of Skywalker is the the the
timeline of how they showed it okay so
raise training and then she says to Leia
something master okay right so then
writing in there they they let you know
that Princess Leia is a master Jedi okay
they dropped it on us like that I wish
they would have shown the Leia Luke [ __ ]
before that scene yeah you know give us
a little background there was some story
that we know you know we it's kind of
like a lot of this stuff in this movie
is like they did [ __ ] it's like just
accept it but you know while we aren't
by Steve we've already established yeah
I had to do that because they were given
a pile of [ __ ] I know I know they had to
fix it back since we're on the Princess
Leia it's like even in the last one when
she she I didn't know Jedi's could fly
too because you know how she flew she
died she was in space and she somehow
miraculously did a Superman wasn't that
she was flying she basically he was just
like you know how Jedi's can move [ __ ]
with their mind she moved herself she's
floating there's no gravity so she's a
magnet you know alright so again that
was the again another sort of
foreshadowing for this movie that Leia
obviously has some power yeah but they
never really went into it in that movie
yeah that's why it kind of catches us
off-guard like how the [ __ ] is she doing
all this stuff so now we know yeah
alright okay this is another thing I
didn't like is the introduction of a new
character Zuri bliss and who's that Zoe
bliss member power that they goes that
one planet she's wearing that's I don't
care about her in their spice runs on
other planets I don't care about her or
oppose their relationship I don't care
let's stick you know I mean I don't see
why they did that well I guess they just
you know they like they like to add when
Hollywood right now they
they look at a movie and they go how
many female characters do we have you
know you know and love interests and all
that kind of stuff yet so how many
female characters are in Star Wars you
can count them you know it's Ray
Princess Leia and the Asian girl Rose
that's it there's only three female
characters and the movie main characters
that you can really like come to mind
right if you notice Rose and this one
had like three lines yeah it was like
the exact opposite before like cuz fans
complain about her now they're like
minimal yeah I just thought I didn't
have didn't write that one down
okay so sorry bliss I had a problem with
that's you know okay you know the all
these names of the people the character
I told you I did research took the
seriously and I want to take this
seriously I and then this is a this is I
have a big problem with this oh oh this
new Jedi power of healing okay I'm glad
you're bringing this up okay again this
is something I have a problem with - I
have a problem with we have seen Jedi
powers now for 40 years and now all of a
sudden you have this this Jedi powers
coming you know what I mean lie and
that's a big one yeah because brought
Bob brought up a good point if that's a
case then Anakin could have saved Padme
back in the day yeah this is some kind
of healing power and now is the whole
theme
you know they intersect you have the
power to say Padme joined the dark side
you have the pool have the power to say
oh I know you know what it's like they
didn't respect the Canon you don't have
saying that it'll respect it and then
like blows my mind that healing [ __ ] was
like now I'm fine with it okay now check
this out yeah go ahead I would be fine
with the turn a little bit so you're not
okay place right now I'm fine with the
healing if it was only Rey let's say
wait a minute if she could only do it
yes let's say this is some power
she developed on her own and that she
has this and she maybe she figured it
out from looking in the old Jedi books
she's not better getting better so I'm
about to freaking read so that have been
lost for years I'm about to lose my mind
why because now you're bringing up a
whole can of worms as far as why is she
the deadliest most prestigious list yet
I threw out the gallon
go ahead she saved the books from the
Jedi Temple she's the only one that has
the books from the Jedi Temple so I'm
okay with her finding some lost Jedi
power and that's what they should have
really let like they should have made
that clear they didn't explain because
remember Matt I know but remember she
will go back into into those scenes it
was like Luke thrown the lightsaber and
then the he burned it you know I'm
saying they didn't explain anything he
had the books okay so you're telling me
you're telling me in those books it's
like you know how like Harry Potter like
wizard spell yeah but what I'm saying is
that Jedi Temple has been lost for
centuries remember okay I'm just gonna
bring essence from so and I know about
Ginny training so Luke went Luke was
there you know and these are these lost
books
yeah of the Jedi because you know the
Jedi had to scatter though that's an
emperor the Empire won no Yoda had to go
to that plant and all the Jedi were gone
so and so the Jedi were lost remember
all right so so she goes to find she's
at the temple now she has the books and
she's been studying them
so maybe shadows that's a great area to
me it cuz they didn't show and that's
that showed the books they show me shows
her looking at the books and her
training sex sequence that was good
we're having a discussion okay this is
what I know about Jedi training from
what we've seen and I'll bring our
Empire Strikes Back because that's my
favorite one
it's deeply with me when we see a Jedi
trying to get like you know like late
let's think of it as jujitsu school
right man Luke was putting in some work
okay let's remember let's remember
obi-wan Kenobi was not a master Jedi
right he was still in training okay and
then when he died you know he was you
know Liotta told him before you go
before you die I want to show you teach
you some techniques about how to like
survive after death right right teach
him everything about the Jedi okay so
Luke's training we're still and with you
on that okay I'm with you on that
knowing to have proper training okay I'm
with you on that but but a main factor
is at least Yoda was there Yoda was
there with him he went to the deck of a
system yeah but Yoda had to make up for
lost but my point being okay so this is
my point let's go back to the Jiu Jitsu
school so at least um you know let's say
you're training at a Jiu Jitsu school at
least Luke had an instructor right like
a Gracie Hart so you're telling me
raised in in a room by herself like just
working on Jiu Jitsu holds by herself
just guessing okay first of all first
I'm just gonna take the other side of
this argument just because okay first
thing Rey was already a trained fighter
okay she already was good with the
sticks from jump they established that
in her first movie
she was whooping ass from jump okay
let's just say that you're making me
upset she was but she was a stick
fighter freaking sword that's a whole
different thing but what I'm saying is
this though if we really go back to the
original movies yeah Luke how long was
Luke on that planet with Yoda a month in
the deck of the system two months of a
system system seven how long was he
there a week that wasn't well
established we're guessing well he had a
dip to go to Cloud City to just exactly
dip listen it was incomplete wasn't
properly trained but at least Yoda my
whole point
Yoda died
I know but Yoda was with him at in the
Dagobah system
- at least he had an instructor okay
Steve you're you're not listening he was
listening he was there for like two days
no longer
listen I'm my argument is Ray as a
physical trained fighter was way more
trained than Luke Skywalker Luke was on
a farm with his parents okay the droids
disappear and he has to go find the
Droid and he finds obi-wan Kenobi
right after he finds obi-wan Kenobi they
his family dies and he goes again I know
I know this way you're telling me rings
okay from the temple who taught ray
these Jedi these extravagant Jedi
lightsaber moves okay little droid there
was no can we show that too there was no
eggs no exaggerated Jedi moves but this
lightsaber I'm telling you whoever I'm
telling you Luke was supposed to train
ray but guess what what did he do when
ray went to visit him on that island
Steve you walked away just whaled milk
this is what I'm saying that boob this
is what I'm saying I don't think you're
listening I am listening the music of
Luke different don't think of Luke's
training he was not a skilled fighter or
anything he was a farmer
whose family got destroyed and then all
of a sudden he's on a ship with obi-wan
Kenobi and then all of a sudden oh no no
no no no no no I get what you're saying
you keep talking in circles I get what
you're saying I know your main point but
my big boy is listen to me listen to me
who train it's like this
okay it's like slap boxing right slap
boxing vs. real jiu-jitsu in the Octagon
right ray-ray
with slap boxing that's not but that's
all that is slap boxing right but we're
talking about Jedi [ __ ] right that's
different you saying she is a fighter
she being trained you're not listening
to me weirdest thing to where I said
Luke learn went to work to learn from
Yoda a badass Jedi Master and Ray went
to visit Luke Luke through the
lightsaber over shoulder went to his
place chilled and drank on whale milk or
wherever the milk from the anyway
awaited Luke learn how to be a skilled
lightsaber person when he was doing that
in the bus system but this is going late
so so so okay let me ask you something
all right why did you keep using this
jujitsu argument yeah so in so how long
can you be a master jiu jitsu two weeks
is it about two weeks maybe three weeks
you're a master Wolfie I know what
you're doing okay way to do is before we
fly know what you're doing let me know
okay let's let's say he was fine let's
relay that to Ray we don't know how long
Ray was living they established that she
was living on this desert place and she
had to take care of herself as a girl by
herself not as a Jedi but she was this
Muslim she was a smuggler thief
forget the Jedi part of it it's so it
means so much to me though okay this is
just about listening
I am listening I listen to your she was
a fine I listen to all that she
obviously works with me and you because
everything we everything we say we we're
like at odds with no we're not
everything but we're not we're not I'm
just
we're not saying the same thing I'm
saying to you I'm proving my point is
Luke Skywalker gonna get a heart attack
has no business being able to fight with
a lightsaber because he was he was a
farmer who family died the next thing
you know he's on a
ship with obi-wan Kenobi and now next
thing you know he's rescuing Princess
Leia
when was the training all right let me
ask can I ask you I would ask you about
restarts you keep you keep you seem to
be defending Rey so you're telling I'm
just this is a hypothetical you just so
when Rey went to the temple of the Jedi
books the whatever the doctrines
whatever so you're saying she could just
download those skills like you don't
listen forget about that point well you
brought a bet you know let's start with
okay okay once again you keep refusing
to go with me on Luke Skywalker
when did Luke Skywalker learn how to
fight with a lightsaber tell me when I
can't give you a specific time because
he never did obi-wan Kenobi died on the
ship in Star Wars that was his trainer
so we're it's one of those things with
like with the rain we're just
speculating like as far as when she
learned all her skills as well when did
she learn all herself what I'm saying to
you but you know what I'm saying is they
don't need to show you know when they
showed that she was skilled when she
beat up those guys that were trying to
take the droid from her they establish
what they were doing in that scene steam
right I want to get off this point they
were establish that was gonna stick this
is the thing this is the thing listen to
me we're not gonna come to an agreement
on this particular subject is are you
gonna bring your face because I don't
want to look at you I want to like cuz I
don't want to stop I don't wanna look at
you right now
I don't look at you because it's like
it's infuriating okay making me upset no
we're not ending it because this
argument part
yeah yeah this is all we're trying to
establish right now I guess this is what
the people want to see who they love
this but stay like this gonna be 50,000
views by they're guaranteed all I'm
trying to establish is that Luke
Skywalker wasn't any more trained
alright then anybody that was a so Jenna
I'm not gonna argue with you I'm not
gonna agree or disagree I'm just gonna
leave it at that because if we keep
doing this no no no because I love Luke
alright I love Lou help me when he
learned how to be a specific time but I
we don't know where ray learned all her
[ __ ] either and we'll just leave it at
that we we don't know we don't know the
movement opens up with her this new Jedi
healing power though they don't know
you're talking about son this is what
I'm saying you're joking around we don't
know let me just can I finish my voice
yeah yeah my finish my point the first
movie opens up with Rey beating up the
black dude and beating up two people
that are trying to kidnap her so all I'm
saying is yeah she was a skilled fighter
and they established that in the movie
Oh Ronda Rousey of the stall where she
know she's just a badass she could fight
well if you're if you're if you're a
girl living on a desert planet by
yourself you have to pick up some tips
and tricks to take care of yourself fair
enough fair okay want to get off right
in Luke say I want to get to other
bullet points agree I know but all I say
is they showed her using the stick and
all I'm saying is if you look at Luke's
chopsticks man I don't care she a sticks
it's not a lightsaber man okay and my
point is when did Luke become a master
with the right I can't give you a finite
answer of what so then why is it okay
for him know when Rey learned her shitty
why is it okay for Luke and not okay for
Ray isn't the question but but the only
difference is who be damper Luke didn't
rated you know raised the most badass I
mean she well that's a whole different
we've all be they showed that she was
trained at that point they showed the
Train you know I'm just lying agree with
you didn't they show the training you're
right Eric you're right she's no she's
the best I didn't say your toys the best
said that she was more skilled than Luke
Skywalker ever was she was more than
obi-wan Kenobi nope nobody so accurate
in Darth Vader
nobody said yes more skin nobody
Anakin nobody said Bank Kenobi nobody
but your I thought that was what your
room nobody said that that's what you're
implying you know what you do when you
assume things you make an ass of
yourself all right
nobody said that then then I'll just
nobody joins to the viewers and
listeners nobody said that okay I'll say
it for the 17th time right
nobody says great this is not good
because I don't know I was starting to
sweat I always sweat when I come here oh
this is why I said I had to oh this why
open the door and had the fan on okay
okay get to your next book I wanna get
are you having fun yeah
great you made a point your point was
that Ray they you don't understand why
she's so good you know I wrote these
bullet points down I have no idea that
we're gonna have like a sweat heavy
every I know cuz you like doing this you
like disagreeing I don't like
disagreeing and fighting yes you do I
know you're the only one fighting you're
the one who keeps I know and I'm
omitting it right now on your on your
platform fine so to the viewers and
listening listeners I apologize I got a
little bit too personal yeah as far as
my attachment with Luke Skywalker more
family I got a little bit too personal
because I'm such a big fan of like just
what his trajectory and I didn't like
the way the way they portrayed him on
the last three and that's that I'll
leave it at that and yeah really a fan
of like what would he turned into either
yeah but but anyways the point is okay
so now she is like so now she's whatever
you know like what I'm saying is let's
get back to it we were talking about why
is Leia all of a sudden a master I
didn't like how they figured that out
but what I'm saying is I like what you
doing she did have the bring it back I
was always here with you when you were
these are
it just it just I don't know why it
fuels me so much you know it goes back
to what we're doing prison of elders and
you're like Steve go to the right I'm
sweating it's like the way you talk to
me is like because you're like my third
like the other brother you know you're
like oh god my other brother is talking
to me this way calm down all right I
have Expos app okay next bullet but
these are all negatives this is your
negative section this is my negative
section yeah I only have a few more
maybe one or two more I didn't like how
that we're supposed to just accept that
there was a fleet of stardestroyers just
chillin dude 100 with you oh my god
because so he agrees with one thing
thank you God my god oh my god that
makes me feel so good first of all Steve
we agree you just don't listen
I was listening no I was going in and
out because of my mind let's thank you
reggae goes to a hamster wheel yeah so
in and out cuz you listening you catch
me off guard with a lot of your stuff
but it is kind of like take it in it's
like you you have your own lightsaber
Chinese star and you hit your hit me in
the gut okay start the story so you're
telling me yeah go on
cuz I'm with you on this there's just
350 Star Destroyers yeah just just just
in from this world by chillin like
nobody knows it where's this crew
there's a whole crew there's 10,000
shipyard and they're in the cafeteria
waiting for a war to begin this that
last war and here's what's ridiculous
about it to these particular Star
Destroyers apparently had a gun that was
equivalent to the gun so a Death Star to
a [ __ ] so Death Star why would you
wait to have 300 when all you need is
like three of them did you know go out
and destroy [ __ ] no I agree with you
that part was just ridiculous because
when I saw that in it kind of like the
the seed was planted cuz I was like it
the trailer yeah I said you know they
have that one edit where it shows it for
like I said yeah like what yeah what's
that I was confused I'm like whoa those
are [ __ ] those are star destroyed yeah
what are they doing out there and
there's whole crews on that like what's
happen but Steve look can we also circle
back to something because I'm one of the
main points that you're making did I go
on board with you with yes this so
anyway this is what started the original
argument by Linux we should get back to
this so ray Jedi's all of a sudden have
healing power okay I guess all right but
what I'm saying is I'm ranting that in
my head as it was in the books that have
been lost fair enough okay that's that
all right but they messed that up with
us with kylo Ren cuz didn't he heal her
but anyways my point is he did so what
my point is like so even the sis don't
know about this healing because if they
knew about the healing why would the
[ __ ] in for being a [ __ ] cyborg
machine keeping him alive when they
don't we have some Sith Lords with Jedi
power they would have been able to heal
they know that's closely related to that
theme is them remember the medic
lorian's
yeah well there is a whole concept of
the medical revived like life or
something like that's but there that was
very vague as well we didn't know much
about the medic lorian's and the ability
like but but this is a whole different
thing is like oh I answer it in my head
I'm justifying it by she has these
ancient Jedi books and she looked him
and it was like oh [ __ ] Jedi's K he'll
you know on page 7 she was like oh she a
page 7 you can heal and she's been
practicing it and that's why she did it
on the snake okay so and they were just
foreshadowing that for the healing so he
heals kylo Ren after she needs him you
know you know and then then they and
then they D they heal the Emperor steals
their energy whatever it is like that so
I I'm with you on like now on that same
note
here's another power that I'm not with
go ahead all of a sudden they could just
teleport [ __ ] what do you mean you know
how they do this thing now where ray
that everybody can talk to each other in
in the force in their mind in their mind
so they so that's something
they never showed before so they added
that okay but but within this whatever's
happening these Jedi powers are bringing
things from the other place cuz remember
how like she had this lightsaber like
this that he had it next you're right
what I'm saying is teleportation
so verse right when I get it I get it so
they're now able to teleport [ __ ] but
they didn't even do that in the [ __ ]
movie before
remember when Luke is he's he's
transmitting himself to fool kylo Ren
yeah he goes and sees Leia and he gives
her the necklace but when he dies the
necklace disappears why did he just
teleport the necklace if that's one of
the powers I know it's like it's like
they just decide a New Jedi thing then I
just decided oh this is just accepted
yeah like no they were be they were able
to do this a whole frickin time so
you're right so the only thing that
makes me justify it is only if Rey did
it first cuz again that was all page 12
she was in that book like okay let me
see oh [ __ ] look I can heal on seven
teleport [ __ ] on 12 teleport to a
different place on the Hockley oh we
could teleport inanimate objects like
what couldn't get to a point where you
could just you know that's what he just
got crazy with the power oh that's how
kylo Ren located where she was you know
she grabbed a piece of article this was
weird so I'm with you in the power I
should have wrote that down that's a
good point
so the the point were really both agree
on is that these like what we didn't
like is these new Jedi powers that came
out of nowhere that came out of nowhere
yeah but I want to go back to a positive
because that you're kind of triggering
some memory I did like the fact I going
back in the plaza I liked his
performance kylo ren's I thought it did
a great job and I liked what happened to
him is his character trajectory
yeah I thought he I thought you change
your heart and everything I thought his
turn to be good was way better than
hating Christensen's turned to bad yeah
you know what I mean but this one I kind
of was like okay he kind of figured it
out his mother that's quite worthy
the only bad thing though was like why
does his mom have to die to like fix him
I don't know maybe the I think it had to
do with like the real actress being dead
you know Carrie Fisher died yeah maybe
maybe this is the way they fixed it
again you know he only had one movie to
make up three or like a that's true yeah
yeah Palpatine and just the whole just
him being alive right a great great
granddaughter like yeah what's took that
story the first ones like Luke I am your
father
yes yeah I thought that was kind of
bizarre but I thought it was bizarre
except today and how did and this is my
last thing well maybe end it cuz I this
has been I think this is the best one
we've done so far
I do mean that okay cuz I didn't realize
because when you're in the heat uh-huh
in my mind I'm like this is a horrible
time I'm having but when I now that I'm
calm after the after we got off Luke
Skywalker now I feel better about the
overall movie review okay but okay so
the last the last thing I'd a problem
with is just like how did help of teens
have survived yes
like he funny like it's like surviving
the Empire State Building dropped in
yeah and now he's hooked up to a bunch
of matrix court like tubing's and to
this main Borg thing like with this with
a Sith collective there and
[Music]
yeah it's alright there's a box down
there okay so um yeah well yeah so like
this is going okay let me get this so
going between half a teen surviving
after darth vader threw them over and
then this huge explosion of like
electricity yeah you know that's that
lazy I'll end it at that you know I I
kind of feel like they were sitting
around like how we got to it let's say
they're sitting around a room and
they're deciding what are we gonna do
for Star Wars you know and they're like
somebody makes the choice like oh let's
um let's make Palpatine alive you know
and they're just like what oh you have
to use something man
they must have argued like we are do you
hope they had a you know what that's how
you get it right what throwing chairs
and deaths investigating room just cuz
we're passionate about something dirty
doesn't mean they were crazy no I don't
know why I got so upset over star no no
Luke Skywalker
you really were getting really crazy
have a problem severe trauma Luke
doesn't sit well with me they would the
way they treated him at the end yeah
she's like drinking well milk out of the
boob in which she's mentioned like six
times that's your favorite part I
thought it was weird too yeah
but but at the same time though I did
like him I did I did like him not those
trash can right I did like him not like
having a problem with the Jedi you know
cuz I have a problem with the Jedi too I
have a severe problem yeah I think I
think it's a weird I think the whole
dark side like that whole [ __ ] is weird
it's just left in this you know it's
just like interpretation now power
everyone can sense it that's not what I
mean but I'm just saying I think Luke
saw that too Jedi the whole Jedi
religion was wasn't his what it was all
held up to me and he was like we gotta
end this and I agreed with him but like
there was just something weird about
like this is the first time we've seen
them Skywalker in 30 years and this is
what you're gonna do with them they just
didn't do a good job but that's the pile
of [ __ ] that we were talking about that
Abrams tried to fix but at the end after
all of this that we've talked an hour
about after all of this is said and done
I still had an entertaining entertaining
time in the movie yes me too but this is
the thing that you were true about Star
Wars anyway that you have all these like
you know you can have like a heated
discussion to a Star Wars like how weird
but I enjoyed it it's fun I mean that's
I mean I'm sure there's a lot of people
that would appraise we cannot kind of in
depth about it yeah yeah yeah we could
have gone further because I'm betting
anyway that in closing I think the movie
was good I thought it was yeah for what
it was it was doing
I recommend seen the movie you might as
well and by the way I don't hate Ray's
character I do I actually like her I
think she's a great actress I thought
she did well you know touching moments
um it's just her story I'm just talking
about her whole arc from the first movie
today it's just we didn't know enough
about get a chance you're right I think
where she come from yeah exactly I got
saved
meant to the character again they tried
to tease the fact that okay you you you
can't just have some random girl be able
to like do [ __ ] so they tried to the
whole point of having that scene where
they try to kidnap her right the whole
point of that is to show the audience
don't worry does chicky take care of
herself
exactly that's the whole point of that
just assume that she does because I
forget about him like what about the
what still the black dudes named Finn
yeah
how about Finn was he picked up the
lightsaber and he was going now we're
gonna do another two minutes brother
open up another doorway brother so now
you're telling me Finn look a lightsaber
is a sacred thing that you have to have
a right to pick up but now Finn could
just do it you can make up a lightsaber
wield it see I'm probably that way but
didn't you think didn't you think in
that first movie that they were leading
towards that Finn was gonna be a Jedi
yeah because on the trailer in the
trailer it has him riding the forest
you know besides that I'm just saying
the whole I love him is his carrot
I like him too much I felt like they
they left out so much for his Carroll
mine like that last thing is like
remember he said we never found out what
he was gonna say to Ray remember you're
right and not only that I'm glad you're
bringing this up it's gonna be an hour
and a half guys it's like I thought
Heyman rare we're gonna have like a
romantic interest
like it's almost like somebody made it
there was Union and there the way
they're embracing each other hugging
each other
nothing came about it was more like him
and Paul had more of a kiss I know him
and Paul but they had I felt like I felt
like as they were making it this
wouldn't like to me they're making that
first one and somebody was like well
let's have the white guy white girl on
the black guy have romantic interest and
they were gonna do it right okay and
then somebody said in the middle of it
like I don't think that's gonna work I
don't think we should do that and then
they were like okay well what are we
gonna do to change the story cuz it felt
like that I haven't bro down with PO
know and then that asian girl I thought
that he was gonna be romantic with her
oh let's not do that either
Rossano like there's so much stuff that
they were gonna do with Po and they just
not po fin man that they were gonna do
with fin and they just didn't do it I
feel like this popular wine there's
probably like a storyboard someplace a
fin oh by the way they had like four
different endings by the way I mean I
imagine the nightmare oh and God they
had a month to release it and they're
still did you see that article I sent
you I didn't read it oh you piece of
[ __ ] sorry you have to look at that
okay well kids cuz it cuz it talks about
this what you're saying like in this
article it talks about how Abrams had a
like he gave him a cut of the movie
right and then they cut 40 minutes from
his cut of what the things that he
wanted the story that he wanted to tell
and then this [ __ ] [ __ ] Studios
like they decided that I think though I
think it's the studio they decided to
make Rey and kylo Ren kiss but but let's
finish on this when they kissed I
thought to myself their baby would be
the most powerful Jedi ever like if they
got married it was Alpha Team Skywalker
now I don't solo blood wouldn't care at
that point I'd be out I'll be like
good luck with that years from now well
you know now are you anticipating will
they be was disappeared I was like what
well they do what he had to die he did
so much evil [ __ ] well there will there
be more star wars in the future there's
two money's to cash cow they just make a
new story Oh
different like at the same time that
this [ __ ] was going on across the galaxy
thank you God I'm gonna pray to God no
that was the most heated movie that out
of all of them that was the most we were
you remind me of destiny you and me find
out was you know what you started off
weird people won't get to see that I was
weird tonight yeah you were weird this
whole month I can feel it you weird this
whole month but you're gonna you okay I
need therapy I think more therapy
actually I need to go somewhere I think
you need to go to the tips yeah to sort
out my just wrong just trauma yes well
and we'll talk about that on your part
they will get to you that I'll do it
next time but you had some kind of like
tests for me some weird EP next time
Steve comes on as I'm gonna make him
take the love language test and we're
gonna get his results we're gonna talk
about it so that's the next time Steve
is on next month Steve will come on
so I'm teasing there for you guys so
anyways guys thanks for watching we're
from with Griffin make sure you
subscribe share I'll have as usual
Steve's informations already down there
you probably already know it it's TV
movie show and then I talk about I have
a new music project yes tell us about to
meet ya I called Oh to my pops when my
dad passed I was in a lot of pain and I
started writing and it became a music
project there's its ep it's gonna be at
on stevie levy Bandcamp calm and then
it's gonna be on all the other platforms
that like Spotify and all that
a month and a half later perfect and go
to Stevie B's show all the informations
gonna be there guys go check out the
pocket yeah check out his podcast and
I'm on that one frequently he's coming
on Instagram Q you a NGO you follow me
on there all the information is gonna be
below so thank you I'm glad we made it
through Lord O Lord that was so
difficult thanks for watching thank you
and I see you next